[Music]
thank you I'll just get a glass of water
please I have to save all my money cuz
I'm here to find my sister
she's been taken taken like like by man
who sell hot white virgins to congeal
Ian airs on yours
I am very moved by your story or there
anything you like I'll have a club
sandwich and an order fries she slices a
cake do you want any cake
no three slices of cake and a diet coke
impressive I'm a con artist sisters in
arms I had no idea how small-time I was
until I met you penny why are women
better suited to calm the men cuz we're
used to faking it because no man will
ever believe a woman is smarter than he
is is it valuable $500,000 I like it cuz
it's shiny
I could be departing in even you needed
teach me your sugar baby ways take this
to the gas trim battery person first
listen there's nothing more compelling
to a man than a vulnerable woman observe
wow you just tear up like that can you
make the tea roll down your cheek
oh oh no you try gee are you constipated
[Music]
if you want to be like me you must be
trained before any situation she's ready
he's the mark he's a millionaire
billionaire out there try to face
inconspicuous as possible yeah I'm
working here if this person would just
scoot over
would you mind sir sir
[Music]
men always underestimate us and that is
what we use
[Music]
you let her get away uh she dresses
again sir most min says it sir
don't worry darling she's a terrible
shot that was unexpected
you